i take full responsibility it's not
my fault that it came here wait huh
it's china's fault and you know what
it's not joe's fault that it came here
either
it's china's fault the final
presidential debate between president
donald trump and democratic presidential
nominee joe biden
took place thursday night and some of
hollywood's biggest stars were quick to
weigh in
on all of it the face-off marked the
politicians second debate overall
after an earlier one was canceled when
trump refused to participate in a
virtual format
a change that was made after he tested
positive for covet 19.
the debate was broken up into six
15-minute segments
where they chatted all things coven 19
families in america
race climate change national security
and leadership
but the biggest difference between this
debate and the first debate
trump and biden's mics were cut off
during their opponents opening
statements at the beginning of each
segment
yeah so we didn't have as many moments
like this
the radical left would you miss it
oh but still things were heated between
biden and trump
we can't lock ourselves up in a basement
like joe does he has the
he has the ability to lock himself up
yeah the 45th president of the united
states accused the former vice president
of hiding in a basement instead of
facing the coronavirus pandemic head on
he has this thing about living in a
basement people can't do that
by the way i as the president couldn't
do that i'd love to put myself in the
basement or in a beautiful room in the
white house
and go away for a year and a half until
it disappears i can't do that
that's a lot of basement talk and you
know hollywood had something to say
about it
megyn kelly quoted the prez and added
even biden
seemed to chuckle while george takai
wrote i volunteer to put trump in a
basement for a year and a half
then a little later trump claimed that
new york city was dead
as a result of previously being the
epicenter of the pandemic
well i will say this if you go and look
at what's happened to new york
it's a ghost town it's a ghost town well
some stars weren't feeling that and
pushed back on twitter
alyssa milano wrote quote new york is
not a ghost town but trump's failures
are going to haunt our country forever
andy cohen chimed in tweeting currently
in nyc
not ghost town hi padma lakshmi added
new york isn't a ghost town you clown
and it's not your city
while joy behar dropped the mic quote
new york is not your wonderful city new
yorkers
hate you
then when the debate turned to immigrant
families in america
trump claimed that children were being
brought in by
coyotes children are brought here
by coyotes and lots of bad people
cartels and they're brought here and
they used to use them to get into our
country
yeah that had people hella confused
sarah paulson and kim cattrall both
tweeted about the coyote moment while
bridesmaids director paul feig shared a
gif of wiley coyote writing
this is who is responsible for all those
displaced kids who knew
another thing to file under who knew
after biden said this
there's a reason why he's bringing up
all this malarkey
malarkey became the most searched word
on the internet during the debate
and just in case you're about to search
it now let me save you some time
malarkey noun meaningless talk nonsense
joe use it in a sentence there's a
reason why he's
bringing up all this malarkey but the
most quoted moment of the night came
courtesy of trump
defending his handling of covid 19 while
accusing china of not doing enough to
prevent the spread of the coronavirus
i take full responsibility it's not my
fault that he came here
it's your fault it's not your fault got
it
when the night was done people appeared
to be split on who walked away
victorious
alyssa milano george takai and john
favreau praised biden
mark ruffalo also praised the former vp
tweeting quote
joe biden spoke the truth with grace and
poise and stood his ground against
every one of trump's lies hashtag biden
one
while megyn kelly and curstiale tweeted
that the president
held his ground kirsty tweeted that
trump came across
like a presidential president